so we're going to move on to our our
next type of data and and this data is
is thankfully a little less Grizzly it's
talking about uh the time it takes to
have a a clinical trial uh published um
so uh so as we mentioned earlier this is
you know while survival analysis is
often used in biostatistics literature
for actual survival time that's why the
term survival is in the in the title
it's a general use purpose for um for
timed data and so here we're going to
use a a data that's not actual survival
just how long it takes to get a a paper
published okay so one of the features
we're going to look at on a categorical
variable is this pause res feature that
stands for positive result to so when a
um uh whether the clinical
trial finished with a well a positive
result maybe for a treatment or a
negative result for a treatment or
depends on what the study the trial was
successful right the trial was set out
to to establish something to establish
something yes yeah and either it did or
it didn't
yes okay so let's take a look at these
so the
um we have uh result equals zero that's
a negative result and result equals 1 is
a positive result so we can see that
negative results some of them just never
get published um and that's you know
kind of well known in the scientific
literature that um it's it's hard to
publish a negative result because well
so in this this example a high Hazard is
good because it's the time to the event
which is publication yes yeah
yeah okay
um so uh again we can fit a Cox model if
we want to do a a log rank test or
something close to it we could do it
with the Cox model so this is very simil
similar to what we saw before looking at
uh sex for the different um uh survival
in the cancer data so that P value is
not significant um and you can sort of
see from the plot that you know that
that even though it looks like there's a
bit of Separation The Standard areas are
are quite wide and yeah and for this
this region here there's not much of a
difference much difference yeah so if
you know if we had come up with a
hypothesis that there's a difference in
this period we might have had a a
significant P value but the co the the
Cox the log rank test looks at the the
entire survival
curve okay
um okay so now we're going to include
some of the other um other features so
we're going to drop this Mech is the
funding mechanism used I guess that's
whether it's NIH or privately funded or
NSF and uh fit a coox
model uh and then okay so now the uh
let's see well there's some significant
things there Jonathan yeah PA has become
significant now um impact uh so this is
some measure of the the
um I guess this is post talk once the
paper is published you can measure its
impact and studies that were published
uh relatively quickly um and some are
associated with having high impact uh
that's what we can glean from this one
um and similarly now the the effect for
for positive results is stronger the P
value is smaller so that's interesting
that happens sometimes you know when you
look at a variable just on its own it
might be not significant because there's
other things going on confounding
factors that interfere with a variable
and now when you put in these all these
variables POS now look significant yes
yeah yeah like in a linear regression
context allowing for these other
variables can reduce the extra variation
and then the difference can can appear
more significant
right
okay and so there's a third example
which is on on um call center data and
this is simulated data um and uh the
analysis is very similar to what we've
done and so we'll uh we'll leave that
one for you yes I I we'll just note that
there the one new thing that in this in
this call center data you'll see is that
we there's a multivariate log rank test
uh and that's you can work by analogy
with the log the log rank test is used
when you have a categorical variable
with two levels here we have a some
categorical variables with uh three
levels and for that um instead of a you
know the 2x two table of the log ranks
uh there will be a 2x3 or a 3x2 table
and that's the multivariant um log rank
test but the interpretation is quite
similar so we'll leave that for you to
do
offline